Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here. Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone is talking about this.
Netflix just announced that for the first time in over a decade,
they lost subscribers, and now their stock is crashing.
-Ooh. -Yeah.
Not only did their stock plummet,
but it turns out that all the cash they had in the bank
was just cake.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, apparently raising their subscription fee
every eight seconds wasn't such a good idea.
Right now Netflix is so desperate for money,
they're now googling "Is there a real life 'Squid Game'?"
It's sad.
Netflix is blaming their losses
on fierce competition, inflation, and Russia.
When he heard that, President Biden was like,
"hey, get your own excuses. That's..."
But now Netflix says they're open to launching
lower-priced streaming plans with ads.
[ Audience groans ]
That's right. Entertainment with commercials.
It's an innovative new concept called "television."
Very interesting.
Yep, Netflix is losing money.
You can tell it's having an effect on all of their shows.
For instance, "Emily in Paris" is now
"Emily in Pittsburgh."
-Oh. -It's still good, but, yeah.
-Wow.
-Also, "The Crown"
is now "The Hat."
And finally, "Bridgerton" is now
"American Girl Dolls Being Rubbed Against Each Other
With Human Hands."
[ Applause ]
I'll still watch it, but...
Well, this is nice.
I read that next month President Biden
is returning to his alma mater, the University of Delaware,
to deliver the commencement speech.
Yep, freshmen are actually invited
to this graduation because when Biden's done speaking
they'll be seniors.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I'm sure Biden's address will inspire kids,
especially when he says, "I'm living proof that if you
follow your dreams you can achieve them...in 60 years."
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw that the CDC has officially launched a new center
that will forecast outbreaks of infectious diseases.
It raises a lot of questions like, uh,
"Isn't that what they did?"
I mean...
That's what the CDC does, right?
It feels sort of like CNN launching CNN Plus.
It's like, wait. What are we -- What are we doing here? Yeah.
Listen to this.
Today Vin Diesel announced that the title of the next
"Fast and Furious" movie is "Fast X."
[ Audience oohs ]
It actually sounds like an over-the-counter laxative.
[ Laughter ]
-Zoink!
[ Drum beat ]
-It actually sounds like a FedEx knockoff
where a guy named Dennis shows up with your package.
"Hey, you ordered Fast X?"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this, everyone.
NASA just released a new report where they say
their biggest priority is probing Uranus.
-Ohh.
Come on. -Higgins, do you want --
Do you know anything about Uranus?
-Well, I know it's the seventh planet from the sun.
-Interesting.
-It's also the third-largest planet in the solar system.
It's almost four times larger than Earth.
-That's it? -Um...
It also reminds me of, you know, "your anus,"
you know, like, the words. -Yeah, that's what I --
-Is it the Red Planet?
No, it's a brown planet, right? Uranus?
-I -- I wouldn't know.
Are you talking about Uranus as a whole?
-Yeah. Not a black hole, though.
That's a different... -Yeah, different thing.
-...celestial body. -Thank you.
Well, guys, today is 4/20,
and oddly enough, tomorrow... [ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Happy 4/20, everyone. Tomorrow --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oddly enough, tomorrow, the sale of recreational weed
will begin in New Jersey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. That's right.
One day after 4/20.
I mean, really?
That's like Chipotle offering free guac on Seis de Mayo.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, police say that a man in West Virginia was arrested
after he was pulled over,
and instead of handing officers his registration,
he gave them his meth.
[ Laughter ]
His lawyer was like, "Your Honor -- I got nothing.
I..."
And, finally, did you guys see the picture
of French President Emmanuel Macron
that was going around yesterday?
It went viral because his shirt is unbuttoned
and he's showing a lot of chest hair.
Here it is. Here it is right -- Yeah.
-Whoa. -[ Audience oohs ]
-Yeah, well, Macron is running for re-election right now,
and he actually asked us if he could premiere
a new campaign song on our show tonight.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome French President Emmanuel Macron.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[French accent] ♪ Bonjour, it is me ♪
♪ With my chest hair, you see ♪
♪ Do you think I'm sexy? ♪
♪ I sure hope you say oui ♪
♪ I have good policies for ze economy ♪
♪ I shall make my VP Emily in Paris ♪
♪ I'm as French as can be ♪
♪ I can get you in free ♪
♪ To ze patisserie ♪
♪ The chef is Ratatouille ♪
♪ We can nibble ze brie ♪
♪ Smoke a cig by the sea ♪
♪ Give my chest hair a squeeze ♪
♪ As it blows in ze breeze ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Now I must say adieu ♪
♪ But in twenty twenty-deux ♪
♪ If you all vote for me, I will whisper... ♪
♪ Merci ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ But for now I bid you ♪
♪ Adieu, adieu ♪
♪ Adieu ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show tonight!
Marlon Wayans is here!
Natasha Lyonne is here!
And we've got music from Dove Cameron.
We are playing "True Confessions"
when we come back. Stick around, everyone!
♪♪